more young adult nonsense trains just
not stopping the divergent series
Allegiant so allegiance the third
chapter in this young adult series of
divergent insurgent Allegiant didn't and
things in this chapter Tris played by
shailene woodley and her crew they all
get out of Chicago into this barren ass
red wasteland of [ __ ] and meet up with
Jeff Daniels and a bunch of people out
there and then they find out oh hey the
world can be great again and here we are
Amazon how to explain to me how do you
explain to somebody that in this movie
they have the ability to watch anything
that anybody is doing from cameras that
don't even exist but seriously it's like
the third chapter in these young adult
novels they have to flip it up and make
it completely different than the other
two really nothing in this movie gripped
me I was just I was watching a movie
play out in a way that I knew it would
play out there chapter and Hawaii
adaptation how do you think it's gonna
play out just like this look at that
we're still being lied to
look at that shailene woodley is the
only hope for the universe this movie
reminded me a lot of the Scorch Trials
like right when they first got out there
into their wasteland I was like I've
seen this I've seen this movie wasn't
even that long ago outside and I was
done with it after the Scorch trial and
I'm done with it now I can't say the
movie lacks imagination because there's
some [ __ ] here that makes zero sense
whatsoever they could only be conjured
from somebody who just has an absurd
imagination even if that imagination
makes them write things that can't it
doesn't make any sense the only
character I really liked in this movie
was miles teller if it was just the
first one if I could think back I kind
of liked the fact that he was kind of a
[ __ ] and in this movie he's still
kind of a snarky [ __ ] but he adds
something to this movie that otherwise
just wouldn't even be there I really
feel like that the actor is the reason
for that level of interest can't help
but think that miles teller saw the
script and he was like well if I'm gonna
be in this wreck I'm gonna have fun with
it the bummer is shailene woodley isn't
that interesting she doesn't carry the
movie that well at this point she's just
phoning it in like alright let's get
some paychecks the fact is Trish that's
her character's name even in Tracy's
woes
I err moments those moments where you
just like oh we need to root for trees
right now you don't really root for her
you just watch her go through the
motions in a wooden format I'm not gonna
lie you see when I'm getting this review
up I procrastinated on this one I
debated whether or not I wanted to watch
it but I was like all right hey let's
watch the movie and even now isn't this
the last one isn't it supposed to end
here apparently not because it doesn't
end in any fashion that makes you think
there's not going to be another one if
we're talking about the sloppy nature of
the construction of this movie even how
the movie ends you looks like it's
building up to an ending and also to
just kind of end credit oh all right and
credit should have gone for a better
musical cue right there to really hammer
in the end credits but okay I guess now
we're watching end credits and let's
just I'll leave God'll asleep as in the
end divergent Allegiance insurgent third
it's a phoned-in saga in a world where
young adult adaptations are a dime a
dozen and you don't have to make them
well for them to make money you just
found them in this movie knows that it
exploits it perfectly and in the end
you're not gonna remember this movie in
t-minus one day yep or II forgot all
right so what is the worst young adult
film adaptation for you whatever it is
whatever you think I meant below let me
know and as always if you liked what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more